PS a pass to hubo hubo fires a pass back to weager
with a shot deflected bouncing Puck hubo can't
tuck it in had an open net but it was tumbling
and he couldn't settle it down on time to get
a shot away now race for a loose Puck Dennis
Gilbert back to the puck shadowed by Brandon
tanev Zer tips it to cadri up to posil down the
right side in front for cadry stick tied up by
wber and the puck batted Away by D tan around
the boards gets it ahead now to Walker der here
he goes down the wing with some speed working in
on done gets around done der puts it in front and
the shot never got through as duet had that go
off a foot great speed by der now Yamamoto back
the other way all alone scores Yamamoto on a
breakaway after a great chance at the other
end makes it one- nothing Seattle on the defense
and undone he's an excellent defense and gets it
right in front to Greer great save and then that
long stretch pass from dun right onto the tape
of Yamamoto he goes just above the right pad
below the blocker that's a terrific shot by
Yamamoto has Coleman in front uo tries a shot
that one off Duman stick high and wide back
the other way from the crack of York Strand
in with speed GL save by marku hangs on was
the fourth overall picking he knew that
guy was going to have a long career he's
had a great career here's Everly down
the wing shoots stopped by marks from
with the blocker save weager stolen by Tatar
Everly with baners in front it's tipped Away
by Marr got to stick in front of that pass
flipped into the corner here's Gordon York
Strand now Alexia takes a look shoots and that's
stopped by markstrom as he grabs the Pucket hangs
on right off the a here's a giveaway Sharon
vich down low TS it a front the score cadri
on the power play and the FL tied up a one
off and it's going to come right back to
Alex in front and it's a Rolling Puck and he
just throws it right up the middle to Sharon
govic and in comes cadri for one of the easiest
goals that he'll ever score but what a mistake
by alexc he was not under pressure maybe
a bit of a Rolling Puck but he just threw
it right up the middle big mistake we have
a tie game Gilbert steps in front of brand
and hubero finds Conor Zer now cadri back to Zer
gilber with a shot stopped rebound and cry can't
get a shot away traffic in front so he'll just
fire it back across to weager far side to hubero
huo's pass finds cadry with the shot stopped
by dger Walker doers back on the ice looks
okay after that shot block dropped him earlier
tanv R shot glove by dger who hangs on sharing
goich pass back to Anderson over to
weager weager takes a look feeds it
to Sharon goich fand on then tipped off
a stick borgan actually steered it onto
his own go tender who made the save wber
takes off the other way can plays the pl
deep back to the line to Alexia R shot doesn't
get through pucks it's free tip back to Mar made
the sa and take a look at McKenzie weager number
52 he goes in front with wenberg the puck comes
right there to weager and you're right rck I
think he was just trying to scoop it into the
goal tender but maybe got a little bit more on
it right there and had to be a great save then
Michael back on at the other end spots hubero
in front and Coleman comes in for the rebound
and that was a so weager got a career-high eight
goals this season now that goes in you can't oh
there's a chance in front great stop by marrom
off Tolen in opening period look at that stop
paddle down 1-1 in Calgary that's it textbook
definition right there I would agree with that
huberto lost his dick and an edge as Everly
drops it off to Tatar with a shot stopped by
Mar rebound the is able to settle it down over
the line with a pass to strand back to Vince
dun mccan Dunn borran shot wide big bounce
in front marer came across to make the save
reaches back hunting behind the net Anderson
able to Wi around the boards and all the way
down Flames get it here's Anderson feed to AC
cross weager with a one timer put that wide big
bounce off the end boards right back to Sharon
goic with a rer on goal the dger sees all the
way Flames win it D Simone on the puck hpil fires
a pass to Center gets through to Zer over the line
with catri here's catri shot BL save dger and
he hangs on really good 916 save percentage in
those 15 games this year here's posil back to
the line to Dennis Gilbert Gilbert gives the
puck to cadri shoots and that's swalled up
by dger Banks it to himself Fe to the head
that's stolen Flame's changing K shot a wide ta
cier with a look it's the Flames got caught on
a sloppy change and he missed the net though as
he tried to go short side on markstrom and they
don't get the puck deep right here and all of a
sudden you can see everybody at the top of the
screen going for a line change and it leads to
this excellent opportunity Jordan Everly sees
cier and he just fires that wi that's a bad Miss
by the youngster cier if you have an open Evans
makes a nice pass to Duman and he'll skate the
clock out Kier feeds it over quick shot turned
away by marst oh tricky change up there by Shore
Mar had to be sharp to steer that to the corner
that was a good shot to the line Duman plays
it over Evans one timer stopped by marstrom
S on the way Deon Shore career to d d Simon's up
on the rush over to du du shoots trying to sneak
one in that's a pretty good chance there for du
but dreger's able to make the save Zer on the PT
to C trying to shake Alexia cry goes down Zer gets
controlable the shot and dger gets a piece of that
wonder if that might be alexc for holding on his
aerial on the he may have been y That's That Old
screw will pin him against the wall don't let him
free here's tanov on the attack now comes across
maani St by dger on the draw Anderson feeds it
over one timer fire wide Sharon got a lot on
that big save by dger stops Leno can't believe
it watch X's behind the net he almost gets it
and then Lin home well to the right I like this
set up Jerry gets it right over to Lin home he's
about 2 feet off the goal line and that is just
a remarkable save up by Brandon blew a tire but
feeds it around for Larson quick shot deflected
on goal and covered by marstrom tipped away at
the line by Hanah cry trying to get it through
to posil lifts the stick tan of Hassel posil
in front taken down stopped by dger got the
backand away and Brandon tanv so with a power
move right here tanv has no other the four the
New Year it's on New Year's Eve and that'll be
the flyers in town so the next game for both
these teams is against Philadelphia surprise
story this season with tonella working his magic
on the bench it's a shot the score wenberg able to
fire one in sneaks it past markstrom and makes
it two- on Seattle watch this are going to go
side to side and then McAn with an incredible
little pass right onto the Stick of wber and
he goes High short side you know that's a
really tough one for a goal tender because
he knows when you look at Marksman on this he
knows that there's a player to the right TANF
and so you know you don't want to cheat but if
you don't try and get over there a little bit
blames keep it in Alex will try the other side
now borgan BS it ahead Chi past Gilbert onto its
bers with Tatar bers with speed one added shot
stopped by markstrom loose Puck markstrom big
save off toar all the way around Sher goic
put that towards the N wber able to block
that shot and the Kraken steer it home as they
knock off the Flames by a score of two to one